hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the world quietest
let's play my mic is at its most
sensitive setting I have to be
exceptionally quiet this time it's
currently 558 a.m. and my stepmom who's
visiting is in the other room so it's
time once again to play oh I'm sure that
whatever the hell is over that blind
ledge is going to be both fun and
educational for my guy here Oh God
I don't think my character has any more
bones to berate and here you can see the
face of imminent regret here the spine
has erupted into shattered pieces the
pelvis exploded into various meaty bits
I know that as a cool happening dude I
think I can I think I can still survive
this one there's a pop
uh thank you for returning my skateboard
to me Oh my good friend the boogie bus
please
ow looky buds
the boogie bus betrayed me before I was
even doomed please you don't have to do
this no I'm sorry you got what you
deserved
you bus off came back for revenge
oh yes the sweet serenity of a
phallic-shaped rocket this level is
called turbo dismount program and I'm
certain
I hate everything you stand for
we need to ascend Oh good life car what
we need now is boosting maybe question
mark we've done it we've made it is this
space are we in space
oh no wait let me but yeah I was wrong
where's my car I know where it went if
we wait
oh so patiently I don't know why that
was really funny to me hello darkness my
old friend it's good to see you here
again turbo dismount has been so lonely
without you and you'll always be with me
me and here we see the elegant ballerina
train preparing for her big debut
would what a beautiful you guys don't
know what I'm laughing it probably but
Han let me set the scene for you now you
tell me if this doesn't look like a dick
suddenly being slapped okay alright okay
I'm glad to know that my level of
maturity as if anything decreased over
the years since the last time I played
turbo dismount thank you guys so much
for watching another world's quietest
let's play and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye